Pienso que estamos en la era de las "pinturas rupestres" de las interfaces computacionales.
Como si fueran muy... no llegan tan profundo, o no son tan emocionantes como pudieran serlo,
y me gustaría cambiar todo eso.
Continuemos.
OK. Bien, este es el status quo de las interfaces, ¿correcto?
Es muy plano y rígido.
Y se podría hacer más sexy y hacer algo más agradable como Mac,
pero sigue siendo la misma basura que hemos tenido los últimos
30 años.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Digo, pienso que aguantamos muchas tonterías de nuestras computadoras.
Es apuntar y hacer clic, son menús, íconos, es todo demasiado similar.
Un espacio de donde tomo inspiración es mi escritorio real.
Es mucho más sutil, mucho más visceral...
ya saben, lo que es visible, lo que no.
Y me gustaría traer esa experiencia al escritorio de las computadoras.
Así que tengo algo así: esto es BumpTop.
Es un nuevo enfoque al escritorio de las computadoras.
Uno se topa con las cosas... ahora son físicamente manipulables,
en vez de apuntar y hacer clic: ahora es como un tira y afloja,
las cosas chocan como se esperaría. Igual que en mi escritorio real,
Puedo... dejen que selecciono esto... puedo apilar cosas,
en vez de usar las tradicionales carpetas.
Una vez que están apilados, puedo navegar por ellos haciendo una cuadrícula,
o, los puedo hojear como en un libro,
o los puedo presentar como cartas de juego.
Cuando están así, puedo arrastrarlos a un nuevo lugar, o borrar,
u organizar toda una pila, saben, inmediatamente.
Y por supuesto, todo está bellamente animado, en vez de estos cambios discordantes que vemos en las interfaces actuales.
También, si quiero agregar algo a una pila, ¿cómo lo hago?
Simplemente lo arrojo a la pila y se agrega en la cima. Es una manera decente de hacerlo.
Otras cosas que podemos hacer son
por ejemplo, para estos íconos individuales pensamos:
¿cómo podemos jugar con la idea de un ícono y llevarla al extremo?
Una de las cosas que puedo hacer es hacerlo más grande
para enfatizarlo y señalar su importancia.
Pero lo que es genial es que como hay una simulación física que regula todo esto,
este ícono es, de hecho, más pesado. Así que los objetos más livianos no lo mueven.
Pero, ¿y si lo arrojo sobre los más livianos?
(Risas)
Es lindo, pero también es una manera sutil de brindar información ¿cierto?
Este es pesado, se siente importante. Así que es genial.
A pesar de que las computadoras están en todos lados, el papel no ha desaparecido,
porque tiene, lo que yo considero, propiedades muy valoradas.
Y queríamos transferir algunas de esas propiedades a nuestro sistema de íconos.
Así una de las cosas que se le puede hacer a los íconos, como al papel, es plegarlo, o doblarlo,
igual que al papel. Algo para recordar después.
O, si quiero ser destructivo, puedo simplemente estrujarlo,
y arrojarlo a una esquina.
Igual que al papel, en nuestro lugar de trabajo,
lo fijamos a nuestras paredes para recordarlo más tarde.
y puedo hacer eso mismo aquí,
como en las notas que se ven en las oficinas.
Puedo arrancarlas cuando quiero trabajar con ellas.
Una de nuestras críticas a este sistema de organización es que:
"OK, pero, mi escritorio es un desorden. Yo no quiero eso en mi computadora".
Así que una herramienta que tenemos es la organización cuadricular,
similar a la interfaz actual. Las cosas están organizadas alrededor de una cuadrícula.
Más aburrido, pero todavía tienen el sistema de choque.
Y todavía pueden hacer cosas divertidas, como repisas en su escritorio.
Bien, rompamos esta repisa. OK, esa repisa se rompió.
Más allá de los íconos, creo que otro área de aplicación para este software...
creo que es aplicable a más cosas además de los íconos y el escritorio... es la navegación de fotos.
Creo que podemos mejorar la manera en la que navegamos por nuestras fotos
y crear un cajón de fotos de la familia para ver en la mesa de la cocina.
Puedo tirarlas. Son mucho más tangibles y manipulables
y puedo hacer doble-clic en una para verla.
Y puedo hacer todo lo que ya les mostré antes.
Puedo apilarlas, darles vuelta como páginas, y...
OK, movamos esta foto al fondo, borremos esta otra de acá,
y creo que es una manera mucho más rica de interactuar con la información.
Y eso es BumTop. ¡Gracias!